there were people who got um either all
the majority of this right so I want to
I want to look at this because again
people were intimidated by this I can
almost guarantee you'll get a question
of some variety like this in your
question 15 or 16 to your actual HSC so
don't freak out just take one part of
time and walk through it slowly the
first part is really easy it's really
easy you just had to look at them the
factorials and just tease it apart just
a little bit ok have a look when you
have a look at this result have a look
at the result part 1 have a look at the
numerator what's missing from this
numerator it's all of the N minus K and
following terms right which you can see
here once you write that on the bottom
it's really easy to cancel it off the
top like that you see that it's not hard
to get rid of look at that n minus k
plus 1 is kind of a giveaway that if the
term before n minus K once you've done
that part 2 right um you start with this
line please start with this lion like
it's part 1 part 2 part 3 part 4 we're
trying to help you out we're trying to
guide you through I was amazed how many
people even if you didn't get part 1
just ignore part 1 and try to do part 2
off something else ok there's a crucial
step in there in that when you have a
look at this numerator when you have a
look at how many terms there are going
to be there are going to be the exact
number of terms that correspond to these
guys on the denominators is going to be
k of them right so once you do that you
had to line up these terms because that
allows you to work with this limit here
ok once you line up the terms you pair
them up numerator denominator new
manager of it every single one has got
its matching pair each one of them when
you evaluate the limit I don't care how
big that k is going to get n might that
could be n minus a million when Ed end
gets to infinity it's still going to go
towards one okay so all of these guys
every single one of these approaches one
okay you can't simply say just cuz it
should this whole thing is going to
approach one you haven't
showed that right to show a question so
once you've dealt with each one you can
see all right cool um this whole part
here in the beginning it just vanishes
away because they're all ones right and
then you can just evaluate the Sigma
notation you've got these two which both
equal to one and that's where this
mysterious to appears okay um so that
was part 2 part 3 most of you got the
free mark which was testing the base
case good on you okay now where did we
fall down okay um can I just please put
an emphasis on this I I had to take
compander in the middle of marking this
question okay because we it was almost
textbook all the things we could do role
we did proofs that went like a round
that I had to follow like a maze we we
didn't even say we didn't even say where
we used the assumption like people
popped it in I didn't didn't tell me
that that's what you were doing okay
that's like the main thing about that
please don't do this in your extension
one HSC exam after you I sorted through
all those errors and tried to see the
logic that you had there were two
problems we didn't manipulate the given
result right or we sort of did something
like this we went straight from here to
here right or here to here and we didn't
say why it depends on the domain of K
right if for example k is like cake
could be a negative number or a fraction
or anything like that your your line of
argument your logic it falls apart like
a house of cards it has to be greater
than or lease a to be a positive integer
a lot of you didn't even refer to that
at all okay others of you just cooked
before I get to your question jack um
they said something like this right but
they had something more complicated
there and they just said it they didn't
actually reason through why it was the
case okay so if you miss that like you
can see I'm invoking that to make this
substitution if you missed that you
didn't show me why you lost that mark
everything was about the logic of the
proof
question yep sure that's a great
question because a few people did that
yep so so the question is something like
this if I have like x equals x and then
I'm like oh but X is is less than Y so I
should get rid of that right and then
I'm like but y is equal to something
else like maybe you're like I have some
substitution I can make maybe it's like
Zen okay no do I write any calls or do I
write a lesser than on the next line
okay the answer is you should write a
lesser than let me tell you why these
lines yes I know they all fit together
but we have forgotten because you know
we're trying to save time right we've
forgotten that really this is shorthand
for a whole bunch of extras over there
on the left-hand side we stopped writing
them because nothing is changing but by
not having them there we're just trying
to imply there are X is there okay now I
think you can immediately see if you put
the X there and you realize the exit
imply bit clearly this is not the case
right so we've gotten confused between
the logic that gets me from one line to
the other verses what does the whole
line mean when we don't write the
left-hand side we forget what it means
okay so really there's a left-hand side
left hand side left hand side
continually implied which is why I can
pull it in at the end okay so that's
what I would suggest then you made the
proof okay last part of this um I kid
you not I shed a tear because um this is
actually this this guy over here this
limit is a very famous limit its equal
to e so if you said it was equal to 1 I
found I found a pillow to go and punch
because he'll is like this travesty of
missing out an important mathematical
truth you can't say it's equal to 1 just
because oh this guy should approach 0
well yes he does of her 0 but this guy
approaches infinity so these guys are
counteracting each other and they meet
exactly to provide you the number E okay
the proof of this was not to get e it
was just to use this guy over here using
this result you can translate all of
that factorial business over there on
the
hand side into a very nice simple GP and
so you use the limiting some that gives
you this guy over here there's my
liberty some formula and that's why you
get three okay question could you state
that it was equal to eat yeah um you
know you know what I'd almost like you
to try but but honestly um why I
wouldn't because clearly that's not what
they are trying to assess um and it's if
not abundantly clear from the limit
itself even though it's a famous result
there are lots of famous royalty and
we're going through like why they are
what they are so yeah no sorry not not a
quote for assault as much as it pains me
that's not okay okay can we do the last
photo bit they'll be they'll be very
quick I promise okay um the integration
was overall well done here the most
common errors were number one we just
got lost in the length of this and in
the algebra shifting around okay a very
very common error was right in here we
got these partial fractions out awesome
we're so focused on the partial
fractions that we forgot that there's
reverse channel here so the derivative
of that three minus T is negative 1 we
forgot that part which obviously mucked
about without definite integral secondly
people got to this line and said what of
thought I what to do there I know a new
substitution okay now that was probably
for two reasons two reasons number one
the question tells you what substitution
you're supposed to use and secondly by
doing that you almost invariably got it
wrong because you made it so hard you
made it so hard for yourself so it was
very difficult to get the mic
successfully from a third log to was
what we were looking for questions he
was my well done you got to the end why
don't you calm down as your warm down
okay um now this was exam technique you
had reading time you had
eating time go to this question look at
it don't get put off by the diagram look
at what's asked of you this is simple
stuff equation yeah Queen it is a
classic equation of a tangent show me
some things on a circle look at that
it's really easy to show something's on
a circle and then part three parallel
lines really parallel lines just give me
the gradients and that was the easiest
mark in the paper